daily coronavirus cases that are
accelerating across the u.s
and reaching even more alarming levels
authorities reported
more than 144 thousand new cases
yesterday
another single day record coronavirus
hospitalizations also hit an all-time
high wednesday
of more than 65 000 people that tops the
previous record set
just the day before and the really bad
news is the u.s also had the most
fatalities yesterday since back in may
nearly 1900 people died of the
coronavirus janet chamblion
is in one of the worst hot spots that's
el paso texas janet good morning to you
tony good morning to you the county
judge here is taking drastic action
he is extending the lockdown order here
by another three weeks in an effort to
get the virus under control
hospital beds are scarce here as nearly
one
out of every 10 el paso residents has
been infected
i spoke to a woman for whom covet has
taken a
devastating toll i lost my husband
i lost my brother i've lost four of my
friends
i turn on the news and i see the numbers
you know every time we see the numbers
it's like
a shot in the gut
several governors are taking more
drastic measures also to stop the spread
new york's governor andrew cuomo
announcing new lockdowns as positivity
rates are increasing there
and in neighboring newark new jersey and
it now looks like california
is going to be the next state to hit
that undesirable benchmark
of a million cases as we did here in
texas
earlier in the week boy janet the
numbers tell the story there too thank
you very much